[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec en rien
devant clean
bonjour katia est notre invité cette
semaine c'est eric coquerel bonjour l
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
la france insoumise de seine saint denis
et vous êtes également le coordinateur
du parti de gauche et nous allons
refaire la semaine avec vous au menu
haro sur les absents à l'assemblée
françois de rugy déterminé à faire
appliquer les sanctions financières pour
lutter contre l'absentéisme
ce qui a provoqué quelques remous le
sénat adopte le projet de loi qui
réforme l'entrée à l'université la
chambre haute a voté le texte qui valide
la nouvelle plateforme d'accès à la fac
parcours sup une proposition de loi sur
l'asile discutée à l'assemblée les
députés ont conservé les modifications
apportées par le sénat
et puis le débat sur l'âge du
consentement sexuel relancer un groupe
de travail du sénat se dit contre la
fixation d'un âge minimal et on commence
par cette décision françois de rugy ne
veut plus voir l'hémicycle à moitié vide
les accents seront sanctionnés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président de l'assemblée veut que le
règlement de l'assemblée soit appliqué
une bonne fois pour toutes les absents
multirécidivistes seront rappelés à
l'ordre explications de félix ul c'est
une image qui a excédé françois de rugy
l'hémicycle quasiment vide pour la
réception de son homologue allemand
depuis le président de l'assemblée
nationale la firme
il sera très ferme face à l'absentéisme
une règle existe déjà c'est l'article
159 du règlement si un député est absent
de plus de la moitié des scrutins
publics
ils encourent une amende pouvant aller
jusqu'à 8500 euros
une sanction jamais appliqué et françois
de rugy souhaite changer cela dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée
on dénonce une parole populiste je
trouve ça assez invraisemblable quand on
est député on est pas on n'est pas
fonctionnaire on n'est pas salarié de
monsieur de rugy ou du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale et on n'est pas là
pour marcher qu une pointeuse a commencé
aperçu et ce côté professeur là qui fait
la leçon à tous les autres députés de
rugy c'est un député comme un autre et
s'il veut qu'on parle du statut
particulier du président qui a des
avantages par rapport à tous les autres
députés qui a trente collaborateurs qui
touche le double d'une indemnité on peut
parler de ça et même du côté de la
majorité on soutient à demi mot je
trouve qu'on travaille après peut-être
qu'il faut revoir ça il ya d'autre
systèmes parlementaires qui fonctionne
pas mal le peuple sait que vous êtes
toujours dans l'ambivalence vous êtes
appelés en circo et vous êtes appelés à
paris et vous êtes appelés dans les deux
endroits en même temps on vous ne pouvez
pas vous dédoubler et puis vous passez
pas mal de temps dans les trains etc
je crois que tout ça ce sont des sujets
qui sont pas les sujets qui intéressent
les français et que il faut pas que les
députés se parle à lui même françois de
rugy souhaite également supprimer les
procurations pour certains votes
là encore les députés s'y opposent à y
ait eu beaucoup de
il ya eu beaucoup de réactions parmi les
députés certains dénoncent comme
christian jacob une mesure populiste qui
re nourrir l'antiparlementarisme est ce
que vous êtes d'accord moi je pense que
le françois de rugy s'est fait un peu
cette spécialité depuis le début de ce
niveau là il est assis en phase avec
emmanuel macron chez pas qui donne des
consignes à l'autre mon avis plutôt du
côté de l'elysée vers le parlement mais
on se souvient qu'il ya eu le vote sur
la confiance dans la vie politique c'est
c'était de cet été oui les gens qui en
réalité n'a pointé qu'une seule
responsabilité sur le problème de la
légitimité fixé les parlementaires on
parlait pas de l'elysée et puis alors
seulement sur j'allais dire entre
guillemets des points qui n'était pas
cruciaux nous par exemple on a voulu
introduire les problématiques de
pantouflage les problématiques de
conflit d'intérêt le fait par exemple
que la parlementaire puisse continuer à
exercer une mission de conseil tout en
étant député on voulait éradiquer tout
ça on n'a pas réussi pas un moment
dépassé mais par contre l'espèce de
suspicion généralisée j'allais dire sur
la question des frais bon je reviens pas
je pense qu'il fallait les justificatifs
c'était normal mais toute une ambiance
qui est installée et qui ne peut pas ne
peut pas être mieux ne pas été relation
avec le fait que dans le même temps se
prépare une loi qui vise à diminuer le
nombre de parlementaires donc je pense
que tout ça renforce l'aspect très
présidentialise la vème république et
que françois de rugy y participent
pourrait rappeler qu'il n'est pas
surveillant général et vous citer un
exemple qui est un très bon exemple la
question du manque de députés lors de
l'accord franco allemand qui touchait
fait beaucoup les dépliants marche mais
il faut que françois de rugy face le
lui-même en tire les conséquences
le parlement allemand jeudi et elle
matin d'un style sur la même question
ils ont eu le droit d'amendement le
droit de présenter des textes
alternatives dont il y avait une vraie
vie parlementaire nous dans le même
temps françois de rugy renvoyer un tacle
30 décembre
il fallait donner son accord même pas
l'amendé donné son accord oui ou non
pour le 4 janvier en pleines fêtes de
fin d'année donc tout ça n'est pas
respecté le parlement si vous voulez
plus de monde il fallait qu'ils prennent
plus au sérieux son texte et qu'il en
fasse un vrai des biens problème
entre françois de rugy la france
insoumise seulement avec nous vous avez
remarqué c'est unanime
je pense que françois de rugy se prend
pour un surveillant général certain
moment où je les ai déjà dit j'avais dit
que je je je je trouve qu'il a une façon
de faire par l'ample quand tout d'un
coup ils est-il
il entend un peu trop de bruit au niveau
des questions l'actualité qu'il dit si
on continue à appliquer sont actualisés
mais c'est une méthode brutale mais
c'est un togolais c'est pas sa fonction
je rappelle c'est un député comme un
autre puis motion veut parler de
l'absence moi je veux bien qu'on parle
de la présence de françois de rugy dans
l'assemblée on va et qu'on le fasse au
prorata du fait qu'il a le double
d'indemnités allons-y ve mettant tous
l'assemblée nationale française non je
ne trouve pas non je trouve que femme
moi je suis nouveau député vous le savez
danger bas j'ai pas de point de
comparaison
mais j'estime que sa façon de gérer les
choses est très politique origines voilà
je l'avais dit à un moment donné je
trouve qu'il mérite de plus en plus on
t'aime en tout cas arrêtons avec l'anti
parlementarisme et y compris d'ailleurs
je voyais à des mesures et bas puis
qu'on l'ait c'est pas la peine d'en
faire dans le faire du bruit et de
laisser penser tout d'un coup qu'il y
aurait plus d'absences un autre exemple
et j'arrête là qu'on fasse aussi en
sorte que par exemple qu'on est en
commission ils puissent pas y avoir de
votre public en même temps il ya deux
jours on se retrouve en commission je
vous rappelle que souvent le député
connaissons pas un mystique
je vous dis d'autant plus à l'aise c'est
que d'après des associations j'étais le
deuxième le plus actif à la fin de
l'année on est souvent en commission en
même temps bah c'est pas normal d'avoir
un vote public pashi 20 commissions
actives
on essaye d'organiser les choses autre
sujet eric coquerel assez voter les
sénateurs ont validé la réforme des
règles d'entrée l'université
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le texte supprime le tirage au sort
pour une meilleure prise en compte des
débouchés après le bac mais la nouvelle
plateforme informatique appelé parcours
sub suscite des inquiétudes clément
perreault plus que l'épaisse couche de
neige qui s'est formée dans la cour
d'entrée ce qui préoccupe au ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur c'est le bon
fonctionnement de la plateforme parcours
sup
soucieuse que cet outil fraîchement mise
en place ne soit pas aussitôt décriées
la ministre a présenté aujourd'hui un
comité scientifique et éthique
composé de six experts indépendants
objectif garantir un fonctionnement
fiable et transparent de la plateforme
d'orientation au fur et à mesure que la
plateforme basse et déployés il ya une
il y ait un regard extérieur qui
permettent de regarder comment la
plateforme se déploie est ce que on a
bien une application de la loi et de la
réglementation tel que c'est prévu s'est
d'ailleurs vérifié que l'algorithme
porte bien le projet politique qui est
celui du gouvernement algorithmes le mot
est lâché et assumer même s'il fait
parfois réagir quand on associe à une
forme de tirage au sort ou de sélection
la ministre et les experts insistent la
plateforme ne doit en aucun cas décider
à la place de l'étudiant il ya pas mal
de fantasmes parce que en gros les gens
ne savent pas ce que c'est qu'un
algorithme comment ça marche
comment s'est construit et qu'est ce que
ça fait donc là nous sommes dans un cas
où les algorithmes sont des créations
humaines bien sûr et qui sont bien
comprises se sont pas des algorithmes et
mystérieux du tout pour le groupe
socialiste au sénat la nomination de ce
comité scientifique montre qu'il existe
bien des incertitudes autour de la
plateforme parcours sup dont la mise en
place et jugé précipité et j'espère que
ce comité scientifique sera un moment
acté un certain nombre de points qui
pourraient dans le traitement des
données delà des parcours super parce
qu'il ya aussi la question des
algorithmes et de la transparence des
algorithmes et bien faire en sorte que
les ça se passe dans de bonnes
conditions
aujourd'hui nous pensons que les
conditions ne sont pas réunies
depuis sa création plus de 400000 futurs
étudiants ont déjà utilisé parcours sup
soit près de 50% de ceux qui entreront
dans lens
alignement supérieur à la rentrée
prochaine coquerel pourquoi êtes vous
contre ce texte
mais parce que en réalité on essaye de
faire passer pour une transformation
technique ce qui est un changement
politique majeur
on nous fait croire qu'il s'agisse juste
de changer de plateforme parce que
l'ancien marché mal c'est pas ça qui est
en jeu c'est le fait que désormais un
lycéen qui sort du lycée avec le
baccalauréat n'aura plus la certitude de
pouvoir poursuivre des deux des dix ans
l'enseignement supérieur en fait
poursuivre son voilà parce que moi donc
c'est ça qui est en jeu donc c'est
l'organisation de la sélection
universités c'est la fin du baccalauréat
comme diplôme national
il va ya la deuxième partie bientôt qui
va rock mettre en question le bac et
donc on voit bien que c'est un
changement total de 2,2 ce principe
changement de tracé ce à dire que pour
vous ce projet de loi c'est instaure une
sélection qui ne dit pas son nom c'est
ça bien sûr à partir du moment où un
lycéen call back n'est plus n'est plus
sûr d'aller sur ses études à
l'université
c'est de la sélection alors on nous dira
oui aujourd'hui a déjà de la sélection
le tirage au sort oui mais le problème
c'est que il ya deux choix de politique
on a voulu que 80% de tranches de deux
jeunes français et le bac
eh bien il faut savoir si à partir de là
on adapte à cette tranche d'âge le nom
de place en université qu'on construise
le nombre de places nécessaires et on a
fait l'inversé on a baissé les budgets
en réalité des universités et maintenant
on en est à adapter le nombre de lycéens
qui pourront à l'université on voit que
c'est qu'on voit que c'est une logique
d'austérité et qui en plus un mauvais
pari pour l'avenir parce que plus nos
jeunes sont formés qualifier avec un
haut niveau d'études
mieux c'est pour le pays le texte va
revenir à l'assemblée
vous ferez quoi on se posera bien sûr on
se reposera l'assemblée et on mobilise
aussi dans l'est dans la rue dans l'est
dans les universités les lycées
la ministre a mis en place un comité
éthique et scientifique pour garantir la
fiabilité de la plateforme parcours su
parce que ça vous rassure sacs noirs non
pas du tout non non pas du tout je vous
dis le problème n'est pas technique s'il
était technique on pourrait discuter
mais il n'est pas technique il est deux
principes d'autant plus que maintenant
au niveau des universitaires on pourra
refuser aussi des étudiants donc le mot
il ya évidemment péril en la demeure et
il faut il faut tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé parce que par contre ce que
j'observe c'est que la communication
passe bien
car faute ça c'est vrai qu'il soit assez
habile à faire passer des projets
politiques et idéologiques pour une
unique qui ont des ajustements
techniques et pragmatique là c'est pas
le cas
c'est un changement majeur contre lequel
depuis des générations les étudiants les
lycéens les parents se sont opposés avec
succès et on essaie de le faire passer
en force
c'est une proposition de loi eric
coquerel qui annoncent eux des débats
difficiles sur la question de l'asile
elle était à l'ordre du jour à
l'assemblée l'objectif de ce texte est
de définir plus précisément les
conditions de placement en rétention des
migrants dont les demandes d'asile
relève d'un autre pays européen la
question divise à quelques semaines de
la présentation d'un du projet sur
l'immigration et l'asile un texte donc
très loin de faire consensus comme nous
l'expliquent maïté frémont dès le début
de l'examen de la proposition de loi sur
les du glee n'est le ton est donné par
le rapporteur du texte
je crois plus rapidement nous le
voterons le plus rapidement nous
permettront aux services de l'état de
retrouver j'avais dire le le droit avant
l'arrêt de la cour de justice européenne
pour cette seconde lecture en commission
jean-luc warsmann soutient la version
modifiée par le sénat alors que le
projet de loi asile et immigration
devrait être présenté fin février en
conseil des ministres cette proposition
créer la confusion
on a bien compris que la majorité est
traversé par deux courants de pensée
concernant ces questions d'asile
d'immigration l'idc en vente maintenant
mais au détricotage après qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire
qu'est ce que c'est que cette cacophonie
est ce que vous êtes bien d'accord entre
vous finalement sur ce que vous voulez
entre fermeté et humanité
à l'origine cette proposition de loi
vise à renforcer des possibilités de
mettre en rétention les migrants appelé
les doubles inné des amendements du
sénat sont venus à nouveau muscler le
texte notamment sur les conséquences du
refus de prise d'empreintes
à gauche on dénonce la fermeté de ces
mesures c'est pas la république en
marche c'est la droite en marche
devant ces accusations manuel valls
défend le texte
quand il va falloir re négocier du bleu
ces anathèmes sur les dérives à droite
où ces rappels à la prise de conscience
vont se heurter elle qui est une
européenne convaincue à de nombreux
problèmes parce que pour dublin on va
pas négocier avec le parti socialiste
seulement on va négocier avec des états
cette proposition de loi sera examinée
dans l'hémicycle jeudi prochain alors
les députés ont adopté finalement en
seconde lecture la version modifiée par
le sénat qui durcit le texte initial qui
visait qui traitait donc du placement en
détention en rétention des demandeurs
d'asile qu'on appelle et du bling ça
veut dire ceux dont la zil relève d'un
autre pays européen
quelle conclusion vous tirer de cela que
ce soit la version modifiée du sénat
tels que ça me rassure pas en prévision
de la loi de l'immigration parce que
c'est en préparation
ça me rassure parce que j'avais entendu
des voix dissonantes ont marché
fictivement comme le dit mon collègue du
nouveau bernalicis tu es jeux wifaq à
côté donc je souhaiterais effectivement
que ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord et
qu'il exprime dans les couloirs le dise
à l'assemblée parce que il s'agit de
quoi il s'agit en réalité de considérer
que tout étranger qui arrive sur le sol
est criminalisé d'emblée on augmente le
nom de jours en rétention de 45 à 90
voire dans certains cas 135 on autorise
les fouilles systématiques
on diminue le recours en termes de droit
d'asile de trois jours à un jour on peut
faire la liste
en réalité toute personne étrangère
carrick sur le sol y compris des gens
qui auront le droit d'asile après vont
être considérés comme des criminels on
criminalise les soutiens on va autoriser
et c'est là aussi où les associations
sont vent debout
allez faire des contrôles y compris dans
les centres d'accueil donc tout ça est
une politique qui nous dit on va après
mieux quelque part s'occuper des gens
qui ont réussi à avoir le droit d'asile
bon d'accord mais la question c'est
global c'est est ce que la france est au
niveau quand aujourd'hui du fait de
cause sur lesquels elle a des
responsabilités les guerres la question
climatique les questions du libre
échange et bien on a j'allais dire un
nom de réfugiés qui a
niveau historique et qui ne peut pas non
plus être simplement trier entre ceux
qui ont le droit de savoir le droit
d'asile et les autres se dit qu'ils sont
fous dit ça nous rassure pas c'est à
dire pour vous ça laisse entrevoir une
ligne dure sur le projet de loi asile et
immigration plutôt du côté de la fermeté
de l'humanité quoi pour l'instant sur ce
qui est sur la table oui
donc il n'ya qu'une solution c'est que
quelque part les les députés dans marche
10 bat non pas en notre nom ne se font
pas attendre voilà bah oui faut qu'il se
fasse plus autant on avait entendu sonia
crise sur accepter son nom qui avait
réagi de manière dure il faut qu'il se
fasse entendre
et finalement elle et elle et elle est
revenue sur la plus écoutée
j'espère sur la méthode à la méthode
jusqu'à ma l'agent la méthode c'est le
gouvernement est en réalité l'elysée
décide
et puis au bout d'un moment même si
elles renac sa majorité suit comme
majorité très très godillots voilà
j'espère que sur des projets de société
au moins sur les projets économiques
j'en attends rien je vous le dis
franchement je pense qu'ils sont très
libéraux mais au moins sur les projets
de société j'espère qu'à un moment donné
on va réussir à montrer que c'est pas
possible que la france applique la loi
la plus dure de son histoire à un moment
au contraire où il faudrait prendre avec
sérieux sur les causes et donc les
conséquences
la question de migration contraintes qui
arrive de l'autre côté de l'afrique où
des gens risquent leur vie en
méditerranée sur les cols alpins
parce qu'ils y sont contraints donc ça
c'est une question que la france doit
appréhender autrement que par la
démagogie et autrement uniquement que
par l'aspect sécuritaire autoritaire et
policier
autre sujet de la semaine eric coquerel
après plusieurs mois de travaux les
sénateurs ont présenté leurs
propositions sur les infractions
sexuelles commises contre les mineurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas d'âge minimal de consentement sexuel
comme le veut le gouvernement mais
plutôt une présomption de contrainte
c'est ce que propose un groupe de
travail mis en place au sénat sur le
sujet audrey vieux thann
pour eux ce ne sera ni trêve ni 15 ans
après plusieurs mois de travail et des
sénateurs en arrive à cette conclusion
instaurer un seuil d'âge de consentement
à un acte sexuel serait une fausse bonne
idée
on a rencontré beaucoup de gens de
magistrats avocats associations et
chacun et a pointé les limites et les
inconvénients des seuils des auditions
qui ont fait évoluer son propos à
l'origine
l'ancien ministre défend d un seuil fixé
à 15 ans fixer un âge c'est dire que en
dessous d'un certain âge on protège tout
le monde au dessus d'un certain âge on
ne protège personne
on pose le principe d'une présomption de
contraintes ce qui veut dire que ce sera
à l'auteur de prouver qu'il n'a pas eu
contrainte
quel que soit l'âge du mineur cette
présomption de contraintes proposé par
le groupe de travail se fonde sur deux
points d'abord l'incapacité de
discernement les magistrats devront
établir si le mineur avait pleinement
conscience de ce qu'on lui demandait de
faire
autre point la différence d'âge et ici
les sénateurs s'appuie sur un fait
divers qui a choqué l'opinion
l'acquittement il y a quelques mois d'un
homme de 35 ans pour le viol d'une
fillette de 11 ans les magistrats
n'avaient pas pu prouver le non
consentement
dans ce cas il ya à l'évidence une
contrainte qui s'exerce sur l'enfant par
l'adulte en raison même de la différence
d'âge parmi les 34 propositions du
groupe on trouve aussi l'allongement du
délai de prescription pour les viols sur
mineures de 20 il passerait à 30 ans une
position qui rejoint celle du
gouvernement
c'est une façon de répondre aux victimes
vous en souvenez maintenant quelqu'un
vous crois je vous crois l'enquêteur
prend votre plainte voilà pour le
juridique mais le rapport montre aussi
que 44% des agresseurs présumés sont des
mineurs d'après les sénateurs cela
viendrait du manque d'éducation sexuelle
et de l'influencé d'internet
il prône donc plus de pédagogie et ce
dès le primaire pour y remédier eric
coquerel êtes vous d'accord avec les
sénateurs instaurer un an
minimales de consentement ce n'est pas
la bonne solution écoutez nous nous
lorsqu'on s'est exprimé on a estimé
qu'il fallait mettre l'âge du
consentement à celle de la majorité
sexuelle tiers 15 ans et 3 mois
voilà notamment effectivement en
fonction de la sphère qui a eu lieu par
rapport à l'agresseur et aux violeurs la
fillette qui avait été inquiété
j'entends les les ça veut dire qu'il ya
inversion des preuves donc c'est pas mal
ça c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui qui change le droit mais on est sur
des affaires spécifiques et en tout cas
le débat peut être ouvert sais pas c'est
pas un problème j'entends aussi le dos
le délai de prescription je pense
qu'effectivement qu'il faut augmenter
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
vous pouvez prendre toutes les lois que
vous voulez s'il n'a pas les moyens
derrière ça ne servira à rien voilà je
crois qu'il faut pas d'hypocrisie là
dessus j'ai vu par exemple et c'est une
bonne chose bien évidemment que le
nombre de plaintes pour agressions
sexuelles violences sexuelles avait
augmenté mais si vous n'avez pas les
moyens donnés à la justice c'est entendu
la procureur de bobigny dit qu'il ya
certaines affaires qui ne peuvent plus
être traités parce qu'il ya pas de
moyens si vous ne donnez pas des moyens
des associations je passais entendu il
avait récemment la vf tc l'association
européenne contre les violences faites
aux femmes au travail qui a dû arrêter
son écoute téléphonique pour justement
les faits d'agressions parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens
xi a pas les moyens financiers tout ça
aurait évité la loi ne suffit pas il
faut pas d'hypocrisie il faut des moyens
financiers à tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
en terme de justice et en termes
d'associations combattent et permettent
justement de lutter à la fois par la
manière des ducati ville ils ont raison
à ce niveau là mais aussi justement que
les pleins de cette fois s'entendre sur
les questions d'agression sexuelle alors
on va passer à la partie la plus
politique eric coquerel c'est l'heure de
retrouver notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et jim jara cédant la place à yann moix
les coquerelles on va commencer par deux
questions d'actualité la première si
s'agit de la corse
emmanuel macron était sur l'île cette
semaine il a annoncé qu'il était prêt à
inscrire le statut de l'île dans la
constitution est ce que vous êtes prêts
à voter une telle révision pas forcément
sur la façon dont ils l'imaginent dit
gignac
si j'ai combien vous prie il imagine le
placer dans un article remaniée de
l'article 72 lors de la prochaine
réforme constitutionnelle mais qui aura
à mon avis un défaut c'est que son idée
finalement c'est d'en faire pratiquement
à droit commun possiblement pour toutes
les régions nous ne sommes pas d'accord
pensons qu'il ya peut-être une exception
corse en tout cas il ya eu des votes le
suffrage universel a montré
manifestement que les nationalistes
aujourd'hui était majoritaire tout cas
leur idée donc il faut en prendre compte
mais nous pensons que ça doit être des
exceptions et non pas le détricotage du
coup d'une république une et indivisible
y compris dans les institutions et donc
c'est pour ça que nous parrainons je
serai plus favorable à l'intégrer dans
l'article 74 dans lesquels il y à déjà
aujourd'hui des régions qui ont des dés
qu'ils font exception cette institution
de façon c'est déjà le cas aux corses à
des départements sont liées à la la la
la
au territoire donc on voit bien que déjà
il exception il ya wallis et futuna il
ya il ya nouvelle calédonie je serais
plus favorable vous comprenez le
désarroi des nationalistes après cette
semaine on utilise bas on n'a pas été
entendu emmanuel macron nous ignore
écoutez moi je pense que sur cette
question il faut l'aborder de manière
très concrète nous on part d'une
principe c'est que la république est une
et indivisible pour le peuple
le point de vue là il ya un peuple
français mais par contre les
institutions je viens de le dire il ya
des choses qui peuvent évoluer sa déjà
existé bout et notamment en fonction de
l'insularité de l'accord ce qui
évidemment une particularité est encore
une fois dû de ce qui s'exprime au
suffrage universel
ensuite il faut prendre point par point
ces actes faut pas faire l'idéologie sur
cette question nous on y va on a parlé à
décor ciel députés à l'assemblée on a
discuté avec eux on essaye de comprendre
comment on peut faire en sorte d'avancer
pour parce que la pire des situations ça
serait de déboucher une situation genre
catalogne on avancer et de prendre en
compte leurs revendications par la cik
74 c'est ce que demandent les
nationalistes donc vous soutenez leur
demande sur ce point de ce point de vue
là à partir du moment où vous l'avez
compris nous remettons pas en question
l'unicité du peuple français parce que
là c'est la question la citoyenneté
politique et d'après ce qu'ils nous ont
dit ils sont d'accord avec çà sert que
ils sont d'accord avec l'idée de dire ce
qui définit la citoyenneté c'est là la
citoyenneté politique
deuxièmement ils sont d'accord de dire
qu' il ne vise pas la dépendance dont
qui sont pour rester dans la république
donc il ya un peuple français qui est
définie par son appartenance à la
république
au niveau institutionnel nous on préfère
des choses qui soient des exceptions et
je vous le dis qu'il ne fasse pas cas
d'école
eca qui propageraient quelque part un
détricotage de ce qu'est la france
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas sûr sommeil
mail macron soit d'accord avec ça c'est
ce qui m'inquiète c'est tant mieux on
change radicalement sujet nicolas hulot
gérald darmanin on apprend coucou sur
kukl deux ministres sont accusé de
relation sexuelle non consentie est ce
que pour vous ça peut affaiblir l'action
du gouvernement ou est-ce qu'il s'agit
finalement d'affaires d'ordre privé on
va écouter dès lors qu'on parle de viol
parce qu'on parle de viol c'est un crime
le viol donc c'est quelque chose qui est
qui n'est pas qui peut pas être pris à
la légère
si quelqu'un si un ministre s'il est
prouvé qu'un ministre a violé quelqu'un
bien évidemment c'est pas de la vie
privée pour l'instant c'est pas pour
réprouver je vous dis vous me répondez
ce que sa vie privée non c'est pas de la
vie privée puisque c'est un crime
bon ce que j'observe dans les deux cas
nous et nous ce qu'on demande c'est que
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de mise en
examen d'accord il y a des choses qui
sont sur la table donc la justice a pour
le cas de monsieur d'armin puisque la
justice est saisie elle doit vite faire
son travail de façon à ce que cette
affaire se dessiner et le gouvernement
serait bien inspiré de ne faire aucun
commentaire parce que dès lors que
l'exécutif et des commentaires sur une
affaire en justice
il peut y avoir ça peut être considéré
comme une pression ça c'est pour le
cadre d'un moyen pour le cas de nicolas
hulot
ça rejoint ce que gilles est alors
heureusement que le délai de
prescription et rajoute est rallongé
parce qu'on voit que que ce soit pour la
victime présumée où que ce soit pour le
coupable possible c'est pas bon quelque
part que quelque chose ne puisse pas y
prêter et que justement on sache
en réalité la vérité ainsi eric coquerel
sera le mot de la fin très bonne si des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires ciao
[Musique]
à